Now, you might be wondering why on Earth this is helpful at all, well, remember,
what we're trying to do here. Since we can't factor this expression, we need a
different way to find the x-intercepts. Here, we can tell that we're getting
close to being able to do that. At some point, we want to set y equal to zero,
and now we only have x written in one spot in our equation, rather than in two.
We know how to take square roots, so I feel like we're getting pretty close. At
this point, we need to think about the difference of squares again. Remember
that if we have a squared minus b squared, we can factor this as a minus b times
a plus b. Here, we have one term that's clearly squared, so maybe we can use
this technique to help us out. Now, 6 doesn't look like a squared number, but
that doesn't really matter. We can stil,l of course, take the square root of 6
and get a number. It may not be an integer but it is a real number. What I would
like you do now is keeping all that in mind, write out the two factors in this
form that we have coming from this expression right here. This is going to look
pretty different from anything we worked with before and you may not think it
looks very pretty but just go with it, this is going to be super, super useful
in everything we have coming up.